Lorien fans my name is Ryan right I'm
Jerry
we're gonna watch a special video today
by the way Rocket Raccoon out everyone
requesting this rocker raccoon has been
abusing the comic boxes making sure
watch this video
Wow so I dedicate an entire video to you
or disrupting my time I precious [ __ ]
reading comment on damn how well you
know persistence you know like everyday
what I do is I pour a bottle red wine
pull out a cigar play some classical
music get my robe sit down on my
leather-bound chair I can go on my
laptop and read comments that sounds
really classy yeah for such a for such
just like a regular activity yeah like
Margaret this rocket racoon fella he
keeps warning me to watch enter the
dragon raid to style that's the video by
the way see how I did that ah well done
you turn a bit into the introduction yes
let's watch it I'm sorry I just stepped
on your toes it's okay he was the [ __ ]
ashamed to tell you now on all the
Sheldon and I had thought there is one
who has turned ways of knowledge and
strength to his own face since he is
perverted
all week old single now his name is
honey defiance of all Lord with ease
he has for a disgrace to the Shaolin
Temple so it is no for you to reclaim
our lost honour I understand this very
minute circle will not be with what I
own it it is contrary to all that you
have taught me and all that soon in
theory please try and find a way to
forgive me I put a lot forget this trip
yeah
feels like a much slower version of rain
yeah like the title makes this sound
like a crazy yeah even though it's cool
still I guess what's that guys in mr.
Han man
yeah good sound [ __ ] clothes I got me
there it is hey it's cool about that I
think you'd be show that traitor to
someone they'd be more inclined to watch
it yeah probably and it was a pretty
cool updated trailer yeah yeah I freaked
I forgot how much I grew up watching
under the drag it's just only that move
only that movie advocates that doesn't
even because I have previous years I
watched into the second and then on my
16th birthday my dad bought me
Terminator 2 yeah and for my 17th I saw
Judd Apatow movie to change my life it
started bantering a lot I'm sort of
speaking more in general I never the
Dragon was like it really was a
childhood film of mine and which
shouldn't be a childhood film for a
child but it was a childhood home for my
of mine and I forgot how [ __ ] classic
that film really is you know Jackie Chan
has a scene in it does he really yeah
there's this moment where he's just an
attacker but Bruce Lee grabbed some way
by the hair and zooms in like classic
like 1970 soon and someone and that that
guy is holding breaks his neck is Jackie
Chan's oh [ __ ] yeah I'm backward you
guys what's he like wearing a trash can
a mustache it was weird
oh yeah right I miss a trait each style
I mean it's kind of yeah so it's like
trading it's like that trailer of raid 2
style wouldn't say like it's the raid 2
style yeah I mean they gave it that sort
of like oh you know we got the elegant
music and it's crime thriller and it's
all gravitas and stuff like that and
there will be intense fighting but I
mean it doesn't really feel like the
right to like I get the point
mm-hmm but you know cuz you got all
these you know floods of various martial
artists like flooding into these places
especially towards the end and like the
raid 2 is filled with those kinds of
fights but they're just not like there's
not
not the same they're not at the same
speed to make me think like yeah this is
just like the right - yeah cuz Enter the
Dragon was like the [ __ ] introduction
into Marshall yes you know but it called
a long ways and fight scenes so I mean
it got me thinking like if you want to
get people to watch more classics you
can updated trailers
yeah that's a good yeah that'd be really
cool actually yeah because it's the
strength of this cuz like it's at first
you're like okay the titles a lot cooler
than the actual dislodge opposes things
suggest but then you get you know to the
end of in your life yeah I should go
back over to watch like you know did you
see it uh I've seen parts of it Bruce
Lee that fucking's of breaking two guy's
neck when he jumps on them mmm [ __ ] I
just think of [ __ ] them the character
law force law or slow Tekken yeah yeah
who was inspired by Jackie K knows about
recently anyway thanks Rocket Raccoon
for recommending after you thank you if
any of you guys who are watching any of
you if any of you are new to the channel
you you can do is you can subscribe i am
the real rejects what this channel just
has so much - it's got like wicked a lot
of videos it's like variety videos plus
hot girls yeah yeah it's pretty much
woody consistent clearly because we're
the first like what like eight months
this channel was just awesome and now
it's like a lot of you and then
occasionally somebody would pop in to
two-thirds of time it would just be more
dudes now we're back yeah we got ladies
now and now and now it's like weird when
there's more than one guy camp yeah
Benjamin Cruz Benjamin Cruz he asked for
a shout-out and um yeah you can have one
shirt Benjamin Benjamin I'm a fan
I'm a fan Benjamin Cruz you got a good
name you got a good name dude Benjamin
you're better than most people I want
you to know that whoa why are you
yawning during Benjamin shut up I'm
really sorry I haven't got much sleep
what so you're gonna just take out your
tightness on Benjamin if you're a
[ __ ] shadow
Benjamin you know it's funny how you're
able to just change my heart like that
and just make me go you know what you
just did the right thing thank you here
yeah
there's your shout out Benjamin do what
I could yeah Dustin white you guys are
amazing on your period
I said you guys are amazing period PS
shoutout to Dustin white dust bucket 11
- PSN US PlayStation Network tag nice
winky-face for you Ryan all right Dustin
white thanks for winking at me I'm gonna
wink at you back that's my own dick oh I
was sucking on my own dick I can do that
Dustin fun bet I can do that can you
really oh that's a fun nose whatever
tried
I think everyone's probably try at some
point it's just annoying cause it's like
you look at it and you're like I can do
this it's and you like get up and then
you can as you're bending it's like your
ass is moving backwards it's like why do
I pain is going away from me come back I
didn't mean it I just want to love you
but yeah Dustin Dustin Dustin wait if
you have please the ocean white big X
Pokemon ninja 10 X X can you give me a
shout out please and Ryan are you a
rapist whoa that's not cool no I'm not a
rapist do you think I'm a rapist no no
no just likes to be so so bold just to
ask
like if you're a rapist that's horrible
why don't you understand that I mean if
someone guessing that looks like a
rapist I asked if they're a rapist
I don't think you look like oh I
definitely look like a realist yeah no
yeah no I I know the feature I'm not
going into this I'm just saying a few
things I care about I'm not to offend
and like rape isn't something I just
don't poke yeah no I'm nothing I'm right
there with you that's what I'm saying
like I mean I didn't exsist any I was
like hey can i have a shout out and also
are you yeah I don't I don't get why he
asked me that guys we're all just trying
to have a good time no I am definitely
not a rapist never even come close no
I'm just gonna try oh hi I mean that
it's I'm just wouldn't do that to
another human being just yeah there we
go